one of the reasons inflation surged this
year is that stores didn't have enough
goods to sell because of shipping delays
all of a sudden those products have
arrived and in many areas they are being
sold at deep discounts but as carter
evans shows us that change may be too
late to head off a recession in retail
business
it's just racks on racks on racks of
clearance it's a big surprise for
shoppers burdened by rising prices is
this really sick 64 was 21 deep
discounts across the country it's a
retail armageddon and retail consultant
bert flickinger says that's good news
for shoppers biggest discounts consumer
electronics sporting goods on apparel
clothes accessories it's cargo that was
stuck in a traffic jam at sea during the
pandemic well now those ships have come
in at a time when inflation is forcing
consumers to cut back too many goods and
too many stores chasing too few shoppers
with too few dollars he estimates some
stores are overstocked by more than 30
percent and there's just no place to put
everything target recently admitted it
needs to right-size its inventory and
the retailer's plans include additional
markdowns we bought 25 000 of these
adirondack chairs from a national
chain the extra goods often end up with
liquidators like bargain hunt which
discounts up to 70 percent but this year
merchandising vp norm rankin is seeing
something different the condition of the
product it's never left the case it
didn't make it to the stores it's not
dog eared or wrinkled or ruffled having
been on the shelf and goods from last
year are still coming we have been in
negotiation with some large retailers on
christmas goods almost 30 million
dollars with a
new christmas product that didn't make
it in time when do you think we'll start
seeing the deepest discounts
deepest discounts will be between labor
day and columbus day
and then
very big discounts right after halloween
and when it comes to returns especially
larger items the stores can't take it is
that a hint for consumers here if you
take something back
you're likely going to get the money
back and get to keep it a very good
chance for cbs morning's carter evans
los angeles